on a strange planet dominated by blue
aliens called drags
we see that human beings play the role
of small creatures that are raised as
pets
so today on cinema recap i'll show you
fantastic planet
the film begins with a human woman
running away with a baby in her arms
we see that she is scared when she turns
around as a giant blue hand treats her
like a toy she tries to escape then is
almost cornered and wounded with
projectiles and in the end we see that
the hand drops her from a great height
so she dies next to her baby
those who played with her were three
alien children who run when they see
people approaching
a family appears and a girl sees a
crying human baby and decides to adopt
him a voiceover of a human man tells us
how his life began there living in the
house of a family that performs astral
meditations and they use a strange
machine to place a necklace on him in
order to control him we see that the
baby was not comfortable with the
necklace but it was used to drag it from
one place to another with the wrist
control and the alien girl decides to
name him tear
over time the human pet learned that
those aliens called drags spent most of
their time meditating in a way that
seemed to send their souls or minds to
the sky however we see that they must
also work and that they have their
executive boards in the whole thing
while on television some drags say that
they brought the human race from another
planet thinking that they were
intelligent life
but that they discovered that they only
had a certain ability to adapt and
organize there is a debate
between whether these abilities can
evolve into something else
saying that they have less of a lifespan
than the drag race but a greater
capacity for reproduction
however this capacity causes wild human
colonies to spread too quickly
unlike the luxury humans they use as
pets whose reproduction was well
controlled we see that baby tear serves
as entertainment for the drag girl who
plays with him bathes him dresses him
and sometimes the boy rebels and bites
her the boy also witnesses how the
family sleeps with machines that destroy
and rearrange their bodies we see that
the drag girl tries to copy the human
eyelashes on her face
and that baby tear plays a joke on her
with black powder which she returns with
a blow another one of the girl's toys is
a rainy cloud that can chase the baby
and even electrocute him but even under
these circumstances the voiceover of
terror admits that the drag girl loved
him
and even taught him to speak we see that
the drag girl gets her education through
a headband that transmits all the
knowledge to her
and that a malfunction in tears necklace
made these lessons also reach his head
outside the house diamonds grow as if
they were plants and one day the drag
girl takes tear for a walk
in ridiculous clothes we see that tear
is trapped between diamonds that grow
around his body
but the girl can break these diamonds
using her whistle tara can also do this
and has fun breaking all the diamonds
and another day we see that some drag
children use their humans to make them
fight joining them by the hair the girl
also wants tear to fight and they put
him against an old man who starts
singing until terror makes him shut up
by choking him
so the drag children have to get him off
over time we see that tare even learned
to take lessons himself using the
headband although the drag parents don't
care because they believe that he does
not know how to interpret these classes
however they forbid the girl to take
lessons with a human nearby as they
believe the human can distract her we
see that the drag girl becomes a
teenager who begins to spend time
meditating and played less and less with
the human
and tara not being able to take more
lessons with her
decided to run away from the house with
the headband when she realizes the
absence of both possessions the drag
girl goes to her mother who tells her to
use the remote control to bring the
human back
and although the girl does not want to
because it could hurt tear
she ends up doing it anyway we see that
tear is dragged by his necklace back
home
but ends up stuck between two plants
and then another human appears with a
gun to remove his necklace this human
also wears a necklace but she says it is
fake and she wears it to deceive the
drags tara then tells her about the
headband and the learnings they can get
from it
the woman takes tear through places
where there are strange creatures and so
she reaches a den of wild humans who
laughed at him because of his luxury
human dress
this den is known as the great tree
and terror is brought before the leader
tara shows him that he knows how to
interpret drag technology so he can help
them avoid traps
at night the leader feeds everyone some
stones that make people shiny
and we see that this is a ritual for
going into pairs
finding a hiding place and mate most
wild humans gather to take lessons using
the headband
but some believe that such knowledge is
not good for humans
so they decide to carry out a combat to
decide whether they should continue the
lessons or not in which the positive
response was a kind of silkworm
generates a new outfit for tear
and then wild humans take him on an
expedition in which they steal things
from drag people
but then another brand of wild humans
steal these provisions from them back to
the great tree the humans continue to
learn about the culture and history of
the drags while tear gets a girlfriend
suddenly we see a creature attacking the
great tree
with its sticky tongue it eats several
humans
however those who manage to escape
hunt the creature causing it to fall and
they take its blood as a drink soon
after
as they already know how to read the
drag language they realize that aliens
have put signs in the surrounding areas
in which they warn that they will carry
out a massacre to get rid of all the
wild humans in that region the leader of
the wild humans decides to set up some
lookout posts to avoid being taken by
surprise
and one night terror is attacked by
another wild group who kidnapped him to
ask him
what he was doing in those territories
tara explains that the drags are going
to kill everyone in the surrounding
areas the next day
and therefore they must escape but the
leader of this savage group does not
believe him because they think that
tara's group wants to steal their
territory the next morning we see that
drags start the massacre using pills
that generate deadly smoke for humans
while using other humans with mass to
find them tara and others manage to
escape but many humans are hit by the
pills and gas
when tara returns to the great tree he
finds that most of his friends are dead
although he sees his girlfriend who is
still alive so they run away taking the
headband with them we see that outside
the perimeter of the massacre both
groups of wild humans have united to
survive and then some drags appear
saying that there is a horrible smell of
humans and they start crushing people
with their feet however the humans
counter attack with their weapons
killing one of the drags in exchange for
dozens of human lives the leader of the
great tree died in battle
so the leader from the other savage
group takes control of all survivors to
take them somewhere safe as they head
there the drag leaders discuss the death
that the humans caused accepting that
they have become bolder and are getting
out of control
they also realized
that they already know how to read the
drag language since they arrange the
supply boxes according to what they
bring inside without having opened them
then they begin to propose measures to
bring humans under control such as
multiplying the killing measures by six
a better regulation of the luxury human
market and starting to use a new type of
deadly weapon against the wild ones
meanwhile in another place we see that a
creature is born and another licks it as
if it was its mother but then it eats it
then we see that the group of survivors
settled in an abandoned rocket factory
in which they created a colony although
they plan to dominate the entire planet
many colonies of wild humans joined them
and that with all the knowledge they had
obtained from the headband they managed
to minimize the drag tools so they can
use them thanks to this they managed to
build two rockets while discovering the
drags plan a big wild human massacre
then one day machines appear in the
abandoned factory
and throw circles of light that adhere
to any surface
and which serves for human recognition
meanwhile the leader of the humans dies
saying that they must leave in the
rockets to another world in which they
called fantastic planet
and shortly after we see that new
machines to kill humans appear
ending with dozens of these per second
the two rockets are launched while
hundreds of humans are left to dive in
the factory in horrible ways
when the rockets reach the fantastic
planet we see that humans find giant
headless sculptures there they realize
that when the drags meditate their souls
are not only sent to the sky but that
they reach these headless bodies to meet
creatures from other planets with whom
they perform their own ritual of
reproduction in exchange for nutrients
that is vital for their race to survive
knowing this humans begin to destroy the
giant sculptures causing panic in the
minds and bodies of the drags
then
the drags decide to make peace with the
humans
and we see that many years later
a drag child takes a lesson in which it
is explained
that after this agreement between races
the drax created a second and artificial
planet that humans called earth and
filled it with cities
the end
if you liked this video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best bazaar and sci-fi
movies my name is tc and i'll see you in
the next video goodbye